you can't have a character in a movie go
this is what I stand for that's that
kind of a dumb way to make a movie in my
opinion my humble opinion the way that I
think you should make the movie is
present them with choices and see which
one they pick
with the density of this book no matter
how hard you try there's no way you're
not going to disappoint some people in
fact you have to make some type of a
dependence you have to choose what story
you're going to tell and you have to
stand by it once you've done it
yes
shut scene with between henry rearden
and Dagny it's one of those scenes that
has a lot of storylines in it but
essentially in my opinion and it's
primarily a scene about a relationship
that's developing impassioned people
seem to be drawn to each other if they
share that kind of you know drive and
ethics henry rearden he's incredibly
intelligent is incredibly decisive
exceptional businessman self-directed
doesn't really need input advise support
you know doesn't need to cry on
anybody's shoulder he's almost that
Randy and perfect man you know probably
the only thing that holds him back from
her idea of his full evolution is guilt
you know he has a sense of
responsibility to those around him or at
least he he deigns to carry them so
there is a conflict there he's not
complete you know he can't just drive
forward in his passion and and be at one
with that will people who love an R and
love the way I do rear didn't maybe
people are always gonna look different
to how they look in your head when you
read the novel
they're just are so you know it's really
none of my business you know my business
is to tell the story as well as I
possibly can and you know what hate us
or love us I'll tell you this is I got
the right rear yeah it's it's difficult
at times to know what to pull out what
to keep in you know how to play things
because the novel's always gonna have so
much more density to it than a than a
film I mean in a film you got to try and
pick two hours say two and a half hours
what's the story you're gonna tell and
you've got to cut you've got to cull
well first off you have to pare down
what's important you have to get rid of
the fat and you have to decide what
storylines are relevant to the script
and since I'm only doing part one of a
hunt of you know I'm new 127 pages
that's all I'm doing its part one this
is really the set up of the book you
know I think that whenever it comes to
Ayn Rand's material I think that you
know movie that doesn't get made in 53
years either
people don't know what the story is that
they're going to tell me and then
there's a battle on that or there's just
you know it's a control issue or you
know because these characters are so
iconic you know that people are afraid I
mean if there's a real intimidation with
this movie because what if would what if
it's not smart or what if it's what if
it's not with big stars or what if
there's no great action sequences it's
like well you know what really
essentially this movie isn't about that
if something comes across my desk is
script or something that I want to be
involved in and I saw this and I thought
god there's no way I could possibly
prepare for you know they just released
the other director there ten days before
they're starting to shoot principal
photography the script is in the kind of
shape that I'd like to shoot it needs a
lot of work and somebody else is going
to take on this incredible pedigree of a
book they're going to shoot the script
that I don't think works they're going
to cast people I don't think should be
cast in it and I could have jumped in
and said you know what stop what's this
movie really about is it about metal is
it about railroads is it about oil
tycoons is it about monopolies is it
about entrepreneurship I don't think it
is this movie represents what's the best
of all people I'm figuring things out as
I'm shooting this I think John Galt is
is sort of like all the great
embodiments of all the great characters
that she written about the Rourke's and
Ellis Wyatt's and the Henry Reardon's I
thought he was the greatest of all of
those like sort of an enigmatic man that
that's why in this movie you never see
his face that's why I chose that and
producers didn't know that until five
days before the shooting
over distance yeah but what I like the
most about particularly this book is the
individual the responsibility of the
individual that you are responsible for
your own life your results for your
decisions and your there's no sense of
entitlement through even if you're
married or if you're brothers of of a
wealthy successful man he doesn't know
you [ __ ]
take responsibility make sure that
whatever you do you own it own it but
this book this these people this
character this philosophy it's all about
individuality